the price of virtually every form of
energy
is hitting new lows in 2020. oil prices
are still depressed after a historic
crash
in spring natural gas hit a 25 year low
this summer
and prices for coal continued their
descent
even the cost of generating renewable
energy has fallen so sharply
that it's becoming competitive with
fossil fuels
the rock bottom energy prices are bad
for drillers and other producers
but they're great for consumers who have
to fill their tanks and power their
homes
and they're a boost for businesses that
consume a lot of energy
like manufacturers and utilities but
some experts say
this price route across the energy
sector isn't built to last
here's how energy got so cheap
the main thing pushing down prices is a
huge glut of natural gas
production skyrocketed in the u.s over
the last decade and a half
as shale drillers unearthed troves of
the fuel we started to
you know build us gas supply just ahead
of the great recession
anticipating a real kind of exponential
growth in
in energy demand globally and we build
capacity toward a demand peak that
really never materialized
the ryzen production swamped the market
pushing down prices
even as the us burned more natural gas
than ever in 2019
then the coronavirus shut down
businesses around the globe
as americans hunkered down demand for
electricity plunged
economists estimate that roughly half of
the american workforce is now working
from home
with workers gone office buildings and
factories turned off the lights and the
air conditioning
back in april when
coveted containment measures were at
their peak overall power demand was down
10 percent as demand sunk u.s gas
producers were slow to respond in dial
back output
which added to the glut driving down
wholesale prices even further
cheap natural gas which is the biggest
source of electricity in the united
states
has met lower power prices here's a look
at prices in 2020
versus past years in new york city
prices were down by about half compared
to the five year average
as gas prices bottomed out a similar
dynamic was playing out in oil
this spring crude prices took an
unprecedented turn with futures
contracts trading in negative territory
for the first time
ever yeah we think of it more not so
much as a perfect storm but rather
you know death by a thousand cuts for
these oil producers so
you know over the years u.s production
grew
you know to some extent global demand
didn't quite reach the expectations
on which producers hinged their their
production plans and we just ended up
with with more
oil in the market than we knew what to
do with and then
kovid was really kind of the last shoe
to drop and
kind of cut things in in a way that
we've certainly never seen before
in the industry we simply ran out of
space to put the oil
within a few weeks prices bounced back
but are still low enough to bankrupt oil
companies
this pushed down gasoline prices across
the country in some regions
prices dropped below a dollar a gallon
though fewer people are driving and
flying
those who are are reaping the benefits
here's the retail price of gasoline in
the united states
you can see at its lowest point the
average price was a dollar seventy seven
down from 2.78 in july 2019
the cost to install new renewable energy
projects is plunging too
the long-held theory is that low fossil
fuel prices would hamper the development
of renewable energy projects
but that's not how it's playing out
renewable energy has gotten cheaper
presenting power buyers with options
certainly in the united states
previously a lot of renewable energy
deployment was driven by
state mandates and now because
the price of energy for these
technologies has dropped so rapidly
many utilities and energy purchases are
choosing to buy wind and solar for
purely economic reasons
this chart shows the levelized price of
different types of energy which accounts
for production costs
the levelized cost of energy is trying
to capture the
total lifetime costs of a
energy asset so it captures upfront
costs
operating costs and benefits associated
with
that system you can see that prices for
new renewable projects have fallen over
the last decade
in some cases sharply that's in part
thanks to a decade of low interest rates
which helped fuel the shale drilling
boom and made renewable energy projects
cheaper too
but it's also due to advances in
technology scaling up that
supply chain really reduced costs
declining costs to produce renewable
energy have resulted in growing supplies
of green power around the world
pushing down prices and encouraging
consumption
in the u.s more electricity was consumed
last year with renewable sources
than with coal for the first time in
more than 130 years
so what do these trends mean for
consumers the lower prices
aren't always evident on your monthly
bill due to taxes and other factors
but the real cost of electricity to
consumers and businesses
has declined slightly over the last
decade
analysts expect at the end of the day in
the long term for
electricity prices to go down solving is
based off of
technology improvements the lowering
cost of wind and solar but
some of it is also regulatory
in the short term however experts say
prices could rise
producers turned off the spigots in
hopes of reducing the glut
and now demand for natural gas is
picking back up
so those two trends don't work together
growing demand on one side encouraged by
the low prices and declining supply with
producers who you simply can't make
things work
with the gas prices where they are so we
think by the winter
you're going to see a much stronger gas
price come through
we think we're at a point where gas
prices are unsustainably low
such that they have to rise what is
certain is that 2020 is shaping up to be
a historic year of abundant
cheaply produced energy